the web play is a really interesting
role in the world of food it educates it
inspires it entertains I think what I
love most about it forever curious is
that it creates a community it's this
vast global network of people who love
food and who talked to each other all
the time and it's kind of like the
warmest most hospitable place to be
because you know that you're all talking
about something that's wonderful and
loving and generous and good and you all
have your hearts and stomachs in the
right place and I think that's probably
the greatest thing about food online one
other thing is that the accessibility of
it is so fantastic you can be in a
supermarket and see salmon on sale and
plug into your cell phone on epicurious
this let me call deputy go and find
hundreds and hundreds of salmon recipes
right then and there and say okay I'm
going to get that salmon I'm gonna get
the dill and I'm done here is dinner so
that's another great thing about online
web food web sites is that the
accessibility is just tremendous you
just it's instantaneous I think that
they're kind of the virtual conversation
going on on food web sites makes food
less abstract in a way I mean you're
you're you're looking at food you're
watching videos about food you're
talking about food it becomes more
ingrained in you than ever before so
while it can seem kind of abstract and
removed in fact it's really not it's
actually making food even more kind of
close at hand
you